[Music]
let's go out to Portland Oregon and talk
to the great Maggie what's up
Maggie hey John how are you paryan dude
it's not even awake time yet in Portland
good morning to you it's like
7:45 what's up yeah uh yeah so um wanted
to First say thank you for having me on
the the show and I watch your content
like crazy especially during this time
in my life and it's been really um it's
been really comforting so if anyone's
ever said you're like pretty much like
Dad for all of us and helping us through
all this stuff um I mean anyways you are
I appreciate that I think most people
watch and go dude that guy's life is a
train wreck I'm not near that not near
that bad we're doing great
honey yeah well thank you for thank you
for being in our gang so what's up how
can I help yeah yeah so my question is
is how do I establish boundaries during
a trial separation um it keep in mind my
partner and I were together for about 15
months we were engaged six months into
the relationship so we weren't married
um we were due to be married August 28th
of this year and we decided to separate
August 16th oh yikes what happened do
you have a kid uh no kids we definitely
did the no no of naming our kids before
we had them and so that's okay I mean
you went all in um what what
um what
happened yeah so there is a multitude of
things um one of or few of which to
which I've owned because it took some
time and some therapy outside of this to
figure out uh for me there's some
insecurities of emotional
infidelity um there's Jealousy on my end
where his attention was going he would
use social media and applications
heavily um on his end there was a lack
of regulation of anger um it' be chocked
up to this is how I express my feelings
you'd yell at me call me names and then
we constantly did this thing of making
up breaking up we both were guilty of it
um name calling on his
end um anxiety on both of our end after
all the responses and trauma have you
know pretty much accumulated um so why
wait it sounds like you're married to a
really really immature I'm not you're
not married you were dating a really
immature guy you're dating a child in a
man's body yeah why why a trial
separation um primarily it's if I'm
being honest with you John I think a lot
of the stuff that he would say that his
rationale was I needed space and I mean
we got a house together and everything
and I moved out of the house and his
rationale is I need to get back to the
things that made me happy because I I
just we both did kind of the what is it
the thenen diagram right our our circles
were right over each other and so we had
an unhealthy like we weren't ourselves
basically and he wanted to get back to
his his life or his what does that mean
more phone and more apps and more
disconnection from reality well it's
sounding like it cuz as soon as we
started to separate I you know be a
bunch of Tik toks being sent my way and
I actually found out we told each other
we were deleting our Instagrams and I
found out through my friend that he
actually
re uh downloaded his yeah so he's done
he's done with you Maggie yeah he's done
and I I I I don't want to be a jerk
about it and I just want to be as direct
and honest as I can I think he's
out yeah because there can be that if he
actually cared well I mean there can be
an unhealthy overlap of that VIN diagram
to use your picture you were drawing
there can be like hey we've got I mean
we've been together a year we're just
being gross we're all Dawson's creaked
out right it's all like we're in love
and it's gross and we're just like I
don't want to wait like that's that's
part of the first year especially y'all
crammed the first year of dating plus
engagement plus we're about to get
married right the first 15 months or so
that's a lot but man things get out of
whack everything is about each other and
that's kind of
awesome right and then there's a return
to reality like I got to go work and I
also really love playing guitar and you
think my guitar playing is terrible and
so like and I like to paint and it's
like I don't want you to paint me like
one of your French girls right so like
that like life happens and you kind of
come back that
way but I don't have to leave
you right you see what I'm
saying yeah and I think that's what's
really messing with my head right now is
and I would ask him and I owned it's my
insecurity but I really feel like it was
an intuition of well then why are we
still why are you still saying you want
to have kids with me you still want to
be with me and all these buzzword
because he understood the emotional
hook that he had in me and hey this this
has nothing to do with your
insecurity you love this guy and he's
dragging you behind his
car yeah and then occasionally he pulls
up to a stoplight and you stand up and
wipe the scrapes and mud and rocks off
of your body and he kisses you out the
window and it feels so good to be seen
in loved and then he hits the gas again
starts dragging you
again you love this guy there's nothing
wrong with you
you you don't have a bunch of things to
fix he can't put down other women on his
phone he can't put down his
phone he has he wants to have this his
quote unquote old life where he sits on
the couch and eats potato chips and
smokes weed and plays with a cell phone
and not do the grown-up thing which is I
love you let's build a life together you
get a vote I get a vote let's make
something amazing he's not ready for it
but in his defense you keep showing up
yeah and for some reason you think so
little of yourself that you keep putting
up with
this right my my my rules for a a quote
unquote trial separation are informed by
the great Terry reel and they have to be
very specific we are separating for a
season for the
following and there has to be regular
check-in time and it has to be there has
to be some rules like we're not going to
hook up we're not going to date we're
not whatever y'all's rules happen to be
be for this
separation um but there's got to be an
explanation why are we doing this and
for how long and I'm going to return on
date X and um it's non-negotiable I'm
going to walk out the door right when
you start calling me names again when
you start right but the way you just
rattled it
off he takes his rage and anger out on
you he is verbally abusive he may tell
you he's not hooking up with other
people but he's sure engaging with them
in a Sexual Man in social media you've
told him hey you're constantly having
your face buried in these screens makes
me feel isolated alone on the same couch
with you and he's like I don't
care yeah tell me tell me I'm wrong I'm
so what I'm doing is I'm pushing really
hard on the other side of the teer
totter hoping you'll push back and
you're not so am I closer to reality am
I closer to truth or is am I missing
something here yeah I mean you're pretty
close with the whole social media uh
thing cuz I mean I found out a lot of
stuff and I'll own that and I owned that
in coup's therapy when we took it you
own what what do you have to own I owned
well to his thing is I went through his
phone and I found out a lot of stuff
that if I didn't go to and there's that
you know confirmation bias there if I
didn't go through it then I wouldn't
have known all the things that I what
that's not confirmation
bias yeah that is I was being lied to
for so long and I trusted my gut was it
cool to go through his phone probably
not but I did and I found out a whole
bunch of stuff that's not confirmation
bias okay confirmation bias is you so
badly wanting him to be the guy you
marry that you overlook all of this
negative crap the fact that he's left
you behavior is a language he's told you
very clearly I'm I'm done with this I
want my life if you want to like we into
little parts of my life I'll have you
cuz I like making out with you and you
know I like it when you pick up the
dinner tab but when it comes to billing
confirmation bias is you throw all that
away and you just think of the one day a
month when he's really sweet to you and
you're like see he's
loving right right that is confirming
this one thing that you want so badly to
be true you're so biased towards he's a
good guy and I want to marry him that
you throw away all the bad stuff that's
confirmation bias going through his
phone and finding out cheating on you is
not confirmation bias that's reality and
that sucks you have nothing to own
nothing to
own other than I shouldn't I should I
should have told you I don't trust you I
want I want to see your
phone right and he should have because
he's engaged to you been like I don't
care here's my
code right yeah that that definitely
didn't happen I mean he gave me his code
but it was like a trust of like you know
I'm not going to go through your phone
kind of in a assumption you're not going
to go through my phone but we're going
to have each other's
passcodes
but this is a whole other call but I'm
super weirded out by
that yeah I don't
know so now now it's like
I yeah it just seems like I was being
strung along and you are right now did y
all both put your name on the
mortgage uh so I did a he did a buyout
and I took I'm completely out of that
whole uh situation um and right now I I
made it clear to him I'm like
I I feel like this is kind of being
strung along and he you know would give
me uh timelines right like at the first
of the year I'd be willing to
do we're we're done with him here's what
we're gonna do you create the
boundaries right so today want you have
text him not call text him and say m
from this point forward I am creating
the boundaries in this
relationship or what's left of it we
will talk again in 30 days and we'll
talk in person
only right and I'm gonna block block
him and you're off social media and you
know what's going to be for the next 30
days eerily quiet devastatingly quiet
heartbreaking silent because you made
plans with this dude
yeah and he's a child and he treated you
like
crap and I wouldn't say that if he had
just broken up with you and just said
hey like this is all moving so fast I am
reconsidering you're not the person that
I want to spend the rest of my life with
that's devastating and hard but at least
he looked at you in the eye like a grown
man and told you the truth right but
he's not he's a coward and he's hiding
behind his cell
phone right and I'm sorry that you're
enduring that and I'm sorry that this
whole thing is so lit up with gas lights
that you have somehow figured out a way
to make this your fault
yeah you're not being insecure you're
being a woman who loves a man who told
her I want to spend the rest of my life
with you I want to make babies with you
here's their names let's buy a home
together and then he was like ah I want
my old life back never mind that's not
insecurity that's
heartbreak yeah and you knew something
was wrong and off because you're a woman
who trusts your intuition and so yes you
violated his trust you went through his
phone which if you're engaged who I mean
why wouldn't you share each other's
phones what are youall hiding from each
other if you're going to spend the rest
of your life together and make humans
together you can't see my text messages
what kind of weird things are going
on that's a whole other call
but you you didn't have confirmation B
you don't have some psychological
misnomer you don't have some
psychological issue you found out he's
cheating on you and that's devastating
and it sucks and it
hurts here's the path forward I want you
to call two girlfriends today and I want
you to say we're going out tonight
tonight and I want you to say out loud
all the things you just told me in
person with him sitting
there I want you to ask
him I'm thinking about this thing being
completely over because I'm taking back
control of my life I'm taking back
agency because I'm freaking Maggie from
Portland and I'm worth
that and I'm not going to pick up little
breadcrumbs of love and little bread
crumbs of physical
affection and try to create a loaf of
bread out of that I'm worth way more
than that there's a guy out there that
would love to cook something nice for
me and is going to respect me and
completely show up and maybe he was into
his phone and maybe he was into his
video games or whatever stuff and but
now we're together he's going to be into
me sorry you're going through it I hate
that for you I hate that for you but
don't ever forget this phrase I'm worth
more than this cuz you are
Maggie